I saw this Wild video today of this
woman who was just in tears and she was
like I just got my first 9 to-5 job
after finishing College you must have
seen this yeah we we talked about it uh
I I can't believe it how do you have
time for having a personal life if you
work a night find job I was like that
video yeah are you no when we when we
started watching that like I was like
okay dunk on this girl right but it's
like look she's not she's not wrong but
she's also she's also young and she will
she will eventually the the pain of
coming home from work when it's dark out
will scab over and she'll just
understand that that's the way the world
yeah like it's rest of us it's very easy
to like to dunk on stuff like that cuz
that's my first thought was the same
thing like look you got to work that's
the way the world works I'm sorry you
just have to go to work but sometime but
when I watch that I was like look she's
if it was like her first day after her
first N9 to5 shifts it happens she'll
change